and helena about acclaim uh is shireen's
niece and joins me now from new york and
you would have just seen her also in
jamaal's report ms sakley good to have
you with us on the program can i just
get your initial reaction uh to what the
israelis have said today
thank you suhel for having me uh as a
family we are not
surprised
this is something that was expected from
the
israeli side it's definitely outrageous
it's
however expected
but for us it was never about an israeli
investigation for us it has always been
about a u.s independent investigation at
the end of the day you cannot have uh
war criminals investigating their own
crimes from day one we've known that
shirin was targeted
and killed by an israeli soldier
so for us
these are merely nothing but
statements
obscuring the truth and continuing to
spread this information indeed your
family statement earlier in the day was
very specific and very direct and
certainly will get a lot of attention
globally so as you say as a family you
know what you want
but for our viewers you know what is
your next
your next move how do you move forward
after this particular statement from
israel and which direction do you move
into
well as uh as our statement has
stated and as we've been clear for the
past four months
we continue to call on the u.s to
investigate
the killing of one of their own citizens
by the israeli army uh we also now that
israel
stated that uh shiveen was likely killed
by an israeli soldier then now this
proves that the icc should take this
case and should investigate into this
war crime
at the end of the day with these
statements will not discourage us on the
contrary we will continue our fight for
justice and our calls for accountability
there needs to be an end to this uh to
this cycle of impunity that israel
continues to enjoy and of course you
touch on the fact that uh the direction
you may be looking towards is the u.s
because one wonders what sort of
pressure you can continue to put on the
u.s considering you do have a sizable
amount of american politicians who have
been putting pressure on the biden
administration to push the israelis for
an independent fair and transparent
investigation
is that where you'll be sort of
directing your efforts in the next few
days and weeks
yes
as we've been doing for the past few
months now um again it's not just our
family that's disappointed and outraged
by the lack of action from the u.s
administration but it's also the members
of congress senators representatives who
have been calling for an independent
investigation it's not just us who are
uh upset and disappointed and we uh this
the members of congress as well are
questioning whether u.s uh funded
military weapons went into the killing
of my aunt so we will continue our
efforts in pressing for
members of congress to continue to
pressure the u.s administration to open
a u.s led independent investigation
because and the statement today
by the israelis was nothing of
accountability so for us it's important
that not only
members of congress but also journalists
civil society organizations and human
rights organizations continue to support
our calls for justice and accountability
mr buckley it's always good to speak to
you under these sort of difficult
circumstances thank you very much for
your time
thank you for having me